hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 6 video you maybe
saw some special things at the end of
the episode so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet and
don't worry we haven't seen the last of
Firefly for good but she might be under
wraps for a little while
the whole episode was about the
dichotomy between people like Gordon and
Catwoman who are all about the gray area
Gotham they're like you know you can't
be so extreme with the way you deal out
justice the way you treat people and you
can't be so nutters that you just go off
the deep end like Firefly this is Gotham
sometimes you got a deal with Batman's
justice to get what you need
so the biggest aganist the episode were
Firefly who went completely nuts in the
episode even though they still kind of
want her to be sympathetic especially
with all those crazy experiments they're
gonna be doing on her in the Indian
Hills hospital that Wayne Enterprise
Zones what I think is going on is
they're driving Michael Chiklis as
character to one end of the spectrum so
Gordon being a hard-ass doesn't seem bad
like they want Gordon to still seem like
a good character even though he's being
the crap out of criminals and they want
Catwoman who is still committing a lot
of crimes to seem like a good character
when she's standing next to Firefly who
just like full-blown jumps off the deep
end starting with number 5 though butch
gets a stump on his hand this is one of
the more fun parts of the episode they
argue about what to do with the bloody
stump can barbara appropriately suggest
that they go Evil Dead and give him the
chainsaw hand not really clear what
barbara has been doing these last couple
of episodes maybe catching up on her
horror films in-between having sex with
Theo and Tabitha and trying on different
outfits but the only thing I didn't like
about them giving them out like I love
they they gave him a mallet but I was
hoping that he actually likes smash some
people's heads in like watermelons or
something something crazy especially
after last week's episode when they blew
someone up with some c4 and they really
ended up throwing it away by the end of
the episode
speaking of which onto number four
everybody is treating everybody else
like complete [ __ ] penguin is treating
butch like [ __ ] fire flies brothers
treat her like [ __ ]
even Gordon is now treating people like
[ __ ] so if the big arc of this first
half of the season is The Reckoning that
the order of st. Dumas bringing to
Gotham if a reckoning is coming to
Gotham for Bruce Wayne then a reckoning
is probably coming for all these [ __ ]
characters that are treating people like
[ __ ] so Gordon probably gonna get a
reckoning Michael Chiklis is character
who's treating Gordon like [ __ ] probably
gonna get a reckoning penguin who's
treating
like [ __ ] also gonna get a reckoning the
real question is is what form is that
going to take like last season Gordon
already got busted down to regular cop
status so I don't think they're gonna do
that again but I feel like the obvious
choice is to have butch turn on penguin
like somehow break his conditioning that
was the whole idea like I thought that
love was with Tabitha was supposed to be
doing when in actuality it really looked
like she killed him even though he
showed up at the end of the episode that
that scene just didn't didn't really
work her outfit was definitely nice to
look at but really it looked like she
was trying to kill him on to number
three though Catwoman and firefly steal
a bunch of money from human traffickers
this is just the show's way of telling
you that even though these two
characters are criminals there's still
people out there that are way way it
works like they don't want you to think
of them as antagonist even though
technically they're villains we're gonna
make them seem good because they're
stealing from people who are really
terrible selling women if fireflies
character seemed a little inconsistent
through the episode like it seemed like
she was going from zero to 60 like she's
like this this really quiet flower who's
really shy but the minute she puts her
gear on she turns into this dominatrix
they're just trying to convey her
obsession with fire think the same way
heatwave on the flash is obsessed with
fire all of the actor that plays
heatwave sells it a little bit better
than Firefly did but to his credit he's
just like a much a much more experienced
actor but if he didn't understand why
Catwoman was like was acting all weird
when they were escaping like she ran and
she did like a backflip over that police
car instead of just like sliding over it
or running around it's because they
wanted Gordon to recognize her cat moves
and like recognize her as Catwoman on
the footage that was kind of a setup for
later even if it was completely
unnecessary if you were running from
police officers he wouldn't start back
flipping over everything he would just
usually like run around it but to be
fair to the characters I feel like the
actors are playing this the way the show
is meant to be the show is meant to be
this heightened comic-book reality like
you have levels of reality that the most
real comic book show out there right now
was daredevil season one regular dude
that's blind getting the [ __ ] beat out
of him trying to beat up other criminals
then you get two shows like the flash
that actually have people with
superpowers they have metahumans but
they play it a little bit straighter you
know you have the Cisco character who is
kind of like the voice of the comic
books just calling things out and then
you have shows like god
that are almost like the literal text of
comic books like like they played the
way you would read a comic book with
certain types of jokes certain types of
moments the best example of that is when
characters don't really act the way
natural people would act like if you
were in this situation and like a little
girl pulled a gun on you you would
probably just rush her
Catwoman's scene where she dropped down
and like she took out all those hardened
criminals that that completely
unrealistic but remember this is a comic
book show so the actors are literally
performing as if they are in a comic
book I wouldn't call it camp but there
is like some energy from the 60s Batman
TV show it can be a little bit weird if
you're used to watching shows that play
it a little bit more realistic but on
the number two a series of unfortunate
strangulations starring the Riddler so
he and Miss Kringle finally do the deed
high fives high fives all around
good job two Riddler for sealing the
deal however he gets a little bit crazy
when Miss Kringle admittedly baits him
into telling her about killing the
police officer all of her dialogue
completes set up but remember this is a
comic book like we already know the
outcome were trying to get to so the
drama isn't so much in him spilling the
beans it's in how he spills the beans I
feel like one of the most comic-book
things that he's done all season is pull
that badge out see I totally killed him
do you believe me now like why is it so
important that Miss Kringle believe him
that he killed that police officer it's
almost like he's proud that he killed
him like he was waiting for her to give
him the opportunity to tell her even
though he kind of made it seem otherwise
last season like last season it was
something he needed to hide at all costs
I guess love just makes you crazy but
Miss Kringle is in a coma now so the
question is is what's gonna happen when
she wakes up will she wake up and turn
him in to the police just add one more
reckoning to the scoreboard to be
delivered at a later date finally on to
my number one WTF moment Wayne
Enterprises the evil portion of Wayne
Enterprises has a secret research
facility that's experimenting on
metahumans or people they believe to be
metahumans that's what the Indian Hills
facility was so I think it's pretty
obvious what they're setting up here at
some point some of these criminals will
break out like they're just they're
teasing characters that we haven't seen
yet and I know some of you are trying to
guess like who these characters are they
they haven't revealed all the comic book
characters are bringing on but I'm
wondering if Hugo Strange is gonna rise
out of this group of people strange is
more of a psychological character so
he's tied more to Arkham storylines but
they haven't done as much with Arkham
this year it seems like this this place
down here is where they're gonna be
surfacing a lot of their big big
villains just because of the relative
ambiguity of when Gotham takes place in
the timeline so you know it's like 80s
90s technology but then they have some
things that are a little bit more modern
I think they have a little bit more
license with the way they do characters
now livewire for instance like this this
chick here I don't think this is
livewire because Supergirl on CBS is
doing livewire and I don't think that
Warner Brothers lets multiple versions
of characters on shows but we will
probably see all of these characters
that they teased in future episodes so
if there's something to be excited about
its Gotham doing full-blown metahumans I
do think that some of them are
metahumans Firefly however is not the
reason they think that she is is because
she's wearing that suit and protected
her from dying they think she's immune
to fire and if it wasn't clear that suit
melted to her skin I don't know if they
removed it but it might be bonded to her
now and like I said earlier they're
they're trying to demarcate different
types of villains you have your flat-out
antagonistic villains like Theo even
though he's kind of sympathetic because
of what happened to his family and then
he had these really tragic characters
like Firefly that are driven to crime by
a life of abuse sometimes it can be
really obvious which characters the show
wants you to root for but they do that
on purpose like they they want you to
see Firefly and think of her as a good
character despite being completely crazy
let me know in the comments though what
did you guys think about the Firefly
character and when do you think that
we're gonna see her again do you think
it's gonna be like a couple more
episodes or do you think that will
follow up with Indian Hills next week
part of me kind of feels like they'll
just cut tour in like three or four
episodes after it's been a couple weeks
and they'll just let you imagine what
has been done to her like the atrocities
that the doctors have committed
experimenting on her and don't forget
Theo is now going to be on the Wayne
board so he's probably going to gain
access to these people bunderslaw the
guy that Theo killed was kind of like
the keeper of Wayne Enterprises dirty
laundry so Theo found out about all
these things that they were doing so he
probably knows about this place so
here's what's going on there's a new
episode of the flash tonight there's a
couple of the videos that I'm trying to
get out but I'm probably gonna do the
flash next because I'm still moving and
it's getting a little
I do want to do a new Supergirl video
there's like a new trailer with footage
of Red Tornado and a couple new
characters so be sure to subscribe to
get that hopefully that'll post by like
Wednesday or Thursday the next video I
post out will be flash episode 4 new
firestorm what a coincidence that
firestorm version 2 is debuting the
night after Firefly blows up and I know
I say Gotham is like the most comic book
II show on TV right now just because the
characters act like they're in a comic
book Supergirl is like a little more
realistic than that but it exists kind
of kind of between the flash and got
them in terms of level of comic book
eNOS if that's an actual word I just
invented it we'll call it we'll call it
a word just in terms of reference
material to give you a picture of where
things are headed like in terms of the
tone Supergirl is riffing more on the
Richard Donner Superman film Superman
one in Superman two more than anything
else so a lot of the energy the comedy
the pathos is gonna flow from where
those Christopher Reeve Superman's flow
from why does wait for my new flash
video to post tonight you can click here
to catch up with Game of Thrones season
6 they just posted a new Ironborn video
yesterday and you can click here for all
my Supergirl videos I have done like
four or five Supergirl videos so far
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high pop I'll see you guys tonight
you